102 countries seven continents 10
million miles of road in 15 years google
street view has circled the planet 400
times here you can see where we've
mounted the street view car onto a
three-wheeled tricycle here it's been
mounted to a snowmobile one of our
earliest trekkers a trolley through
museums places they expect there to be a
lot of change we try to drive those
areas more frequently there are other
areas of the world where we still have
to go back and refresh that imagery
again let's walk through 15 years of
gadgets and gear to understand the tools
google street view uses to map the world
maps are fundamentally about where
things are think about a satellite map
or even the map that you draw on a
napkin for your friend you're talking
about where things are and where they
are in relation to each other and in
that sense street view was different it
promised an immersive on-the-ground
experience of far-flung locales
street view was the brainchild of google
co-founder larry page he had what was a
pretty crazy idea at the time that you
should enable people to explore the
world right from their computers he
actually collected the first street view
imagery he used the camcorder and drove
around the streets around the google
office and brought this back for the
engineers to play with and the engineers
built a custom prototype camera system
that had multiple camera units and
multiple laser scanners the whole thing
weighed 500 pounds the team used this to
collect imagery around the bay area the
very first version which had a small 4
megapixel camera it just took pictures
and we had to figure out exactly where
these pictures were taken using a gps
unit that followed along with the car
the idea was how can we stitch this
together into a seamless experience that
can let people explore the world
[Music]
the lights turned on for street view in
may of 2007 that was when we had the
first consumer-facing release with five
street view cities worth of imagery
collected san francisco new york las
vegas miami and denver were the first
but the project expanded covering more
countries and thousands of miles of
streets all using pretty much the same
underlying process
at the most basic level it's all about
collecting imagery of the world and
processing this into one seamless model
a street view car starts as a regular
car that you could buy we mount a custom
roof rack onto the top and then the
camera gets mounted on a mast that can
be raised and lowered the street view
camera has seven lenses and it takes
full 360 degree panoramic shot a couple
times a second so you'd be able to
traverse the length of a road from
picture to picture to picture using a
technique called photogrammetry which is
a really old technique actually from the
1800s you can take measurements from
photos and you can basically figure out
where objects are how big they are how
far apart they are there's a cable that
comes off the camera system and goes
into the back seat where it connects to
the processing system and the hard
drives for storing all of the imagery
data
in the back there were boxes of cpus and
hard drives in them that would collect
all of the data this typically took up a
big portion of
the back seat of the car and it's
getting stored on basically on the hard
disk this information is sent in batch
and then it's fed into our imagery
processing pipelines
[Music]
the cameras themselves have gotten much
better not only have they gotten higher
resolution going from 4.8 megapixels to
a 45 megapixel camera 75 up to 140
megapixels their responsiveness and low
light is much better apart from
improvements in the cameras the game
changing tech to the street view system
was the addition of lidar scanners first
in 2008 and updated in 2013. the lidar
works with uh you know millimeter
accuracy they're laser radars they have
invisible laser beams that shoot out and
map the world in 3d as the car moves
down the street so it helps us measure
where the curbs are or even where there
are lines of paint in the middle of the
road all this information comes back and
helps us build this very precise highly
detailed 3d reconstruction of the world
every route is planned in advance this
is actually important from a privacy
perspective we try to standardize our
google street view hardware as much as
possible but sometimes there are local
quirks that mean we have to introduce
something a little bit different this is
our main car that we use in north
america and the mast on top of the car
is pretty tall this is so the camera can
see over parked cars that might be on
the side of the street when we first
took this car to japan we ran into a
problem the streets are very narrow and
oftentimes people put up fences in front
of their yard so that their yard won't
be visible from the street and we
discovered that the street view camera
was actually seeing over these fences
into people's yards so we came up with a
custom rig for the japan market and you
can see that this car has a much lower
mast another milestone expansion of the
program was trekker gear which took
image gathering off-road in 2012
we realized there were so many important
places on earth where you simply
couldn't drive a car even in a city
there are narrow alleys there are
pedestrian walking paths we'd like to
take you inside transit stations or
maybe even inside a museum out into the
wilderness to the top of machu picchu
and the top of mont blanc down into the
amazon rainforests and underwater by the
great barrier reef or up in the
international space station the street
view trekker is basically a street view
camera system that's attached to a
backpack here you can see the camera
unit on top with the lenses here you can
see a gps unit and these are our laser
scanners this is the processing unit and
what you see on the back here is a big
heat sink because it takes a lot of
processing uh to handle all this imagery
and the unit can get hot you actually
put this on wearing the wearing the
straps it's relatively comfortable to
wear but you know it's not the lightest
thing weighing in at about 35 pounds you
can just walk naturally and it will
automatically snap photos as you're
walking down the path you can be tipping
from side to side and you don't want the
pictures to come out blurry so we use a
lot of smart software algorithms the
typical trucker outing takes a few hours
unless it's a hike down into the grand
canyon that'll take a trekker 10 days
google collects this imagery themselves
through staff trekkers through a network
of third-party contractors or by tapping
a community of contributors who use
their own 360 cameras my favorite story
about the street view trekker is about
the pharaoh islands some enterprising
folks who live there they wanted the
faroe islands to be on street view as
well we actually sent them the street
view equipment and they used cheap to
carry the street view camera around
cheap view
one thing that we tried was putting high
definition cameras that were facing to
the sides so we could read small print
that was on the storefronts of
businesses think about opening hours
that are on the door of a business that
it's really hard to see from the street
this side profile camera configuration
was paired with machine learning and
image recognition software which was
already in google's wheelhouse the
engineers who first worked on this
project had actually been working on the
google book search project they were
experts in processing imagery and the
book search project was trying to
digitize all the world's books in
libraries so these people knew how to
work with imagery and at first we had
humans looking at this imagery combined
with thousands of other data sources in
order to build the roads and the
business listings that you see on google
maps but the world is a really big place
so it wasn't too long before we started
introducing machine learning
to look at the images and automatically
extract information blurring and privacy
protection has been
built in pretty much from the start this
is a process that's fully automatic all
of the people's faces all the license
plates these are blurred through
automatic algorithms because otherwise
the scale of processing this with humans
would just be too great recently google
unveiled for us the latest camera set to
roll out on street view cars over the
next year our current generation cameras
they're designed for specific models of
car that need to have a custom roof rack
with this we can send it around the
world it has handles to make it easy to
pick up the whole thing weighs less than
15 pounds and one of the key things
about this is it can be mounted on top
of any vehicle at all we can give it to
a third party and they can put it on any
car that has a roof rack there are seven
lenses arranged around the outside and
one that's pointing upwards from the top
as the camera moves down the street or
on top of a backpack it takes a full 360
degree panorama these are heat sinks
we've taken all of the processing power
that used to take up the entire back
seat of a car and we've shrunk it down
we've stuck it inside the camera unit so
this is all you need in order to go
collect street view imagery
google is innovating on the software
side too with immersive view we launched
immersive view which is all of the
billions of street view images and
aerial photos let's say you're planning
a trip to london we can take you to
westminster you can see where's big ben
and where's the london eye and where are
they in relation to each other we can
then overlay additional information on
top of this model of the world if you
want to see what it looks like with the
sun coming from one direction or the sun
coming from another direction using all
of this imagery that we've collected we
can actually put these experiences into
what we've collected from street view
and when you're ready to choose a
restaurant we can fly you down to street
level and show you real-time busyness
and these future rich immersive
experiences this is what street view
will be powering and hopefully it's
helped people learn more about
places around the world about other
people's communities and about their
fellow citizens